[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir einen
blechkuchen der von jedem geliebt mir
kennt diese klassiker diese blechkuchen
die man sich so ansieht schokopudding
schicht und schoko und berlin ist
einfach einfach man liebt sie einfach
also ich hab jetzt kracht wir machen wir
machen jetzt einen solchen blechkuchen
und der geht auch sehr schnell und ist
sehr sehr unkompliziert in der
zubereitung ihr bräuchtet im prinzip
noch nicht mal eine küchenmaschine und
könnte noch kräftig mit dem schneebesen
drin aber ich erreiche jetzt einfach mal
die arbeit und gibt die eier in die
maschine gibt zucker mit dazu und lasse
das dann so ungefähr eine minute lang
verrühren einfach einfach
[Musik]
so nachdem minute einmal sonnenburg mit
rein gehe und geld kurz mit einbringen
lassen und jetzt kommen schon die
trockenen zutaten zum einsatz hier habe
ich mir bei kakao und backpulver und das
verriet immer gerne vorher miteinander
damit sich das besser vermengt und dann
sehe ich dass zur masse
[Musik]
so die trockenen zutaten auch nur ganz
kurz unter rühren nicht zu lange damit
erreicht sie den gegenteiligen effekt
wir wollen ja dass der teig richtig
schön lecker und saftig wird und den
gebe ich jetzt in meine vorbereitet in
meinem vorbereiteten back haben
den habe ich hier eingestellt auf 28 x
22 cm und der teig ihr könnt das sehende
ist etwas langsamer klebriger als normal
kein gewöhnlicher biskuitteig das
sowieso nicht weil wir fed dazu gegeben
haben dann schön glatt streichen und bei
180 grad ober unterhitze backen er haben
das schreibt die ganz genaue backzeit
rein
ich schätze mal so um die 15 minuten
[Musik]
den fertig gebackenen boden habe ich
jetzt ungefähr 56 minuten lang ein
bisschen ausdampfen lassen damit er
nicht ganz so heiß ist und jetzt müssen
wir einmal umdrehen das heißt wir nehmen
jetzt einmal gleich raus aus dem back
rahmen drehen ihn um und machen dann den
bug haben wieder drauf
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir startklar für die
milch trinke dafür nehme ich mir einfach
nicht die ist jetzt ganz einfach aus dem
kühlschrank ihr müsst ihr auch nicht
erwärmen
der kuchen ist allerdings noch lauwarm
mit trinke ich ihn gleichmäßig mit der
milch euch liebe auch diesen part dann
wird euch auch richtig viel spaß machen
stimmt
[Musik]
so der durchtränkte boden er bleibt
jetzt erstmal der seite liegen und wir
machen weiter mit der pudding schicht
dafür habe ich hier milch in einem
kochtopf und gibt jetzt die anderen
zutat mit dazu und ihr findet die ganz
genaue mengenangaben immer und in der
infobox genau
doch jetzt gebe ich da zucker mit dazu
für die süße vanille für den geschmack
und ich mache jetzt eine okay ich mache
eine mischung aus vanille pudding pulver
könnt ihr auch schon dessen speisestärke
nehmen und mehl das nicht einfach dann
also das team fast genau ich mache das
wegen der konsistenz wenn die nur
speisestärke und hatte eine ganz andere
konsistenz als wenn ihr ein teil davon
durch mehl ersetzt und später nachdem
wir das ganze unter rühren aufkochen
lassen haben kommt noch butter mit dazu
zuerst nach dem bisschen frei verrückt
wurde schaltet ihr ihn herein und dann
immer weiter hin
[Musik]
seine politik ist ein gedicht den herd
ausgeschaltet und jetzt einfach noch die
butter einrühren
[Musik]
und im pudding dann einfach auf den
schoko boden verteilen und richtig schön
glatt streichen
so und jetzt muss es ja nur noch
auskühlen und fest werden das dauert so
ungefähr ich würde sagen eine stunde bis
eineinhalb es kommt immer darauf an erst
mal auf zimmertemperatur abkühlen lassen
nichts heißt es in den kühlschrank
stellen und dann eben noch mal in den
kühlschrank legen und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder für den abschluss ist
gleich selbst ist bei mir als abgekühlt
und ich mache die letzte schicht die
schokoglasur ich persönlich mag bei dem
rezept vollmilch kuvertüre ihr könntet
auch eins zu eins einfach zeit später
kulturen das ist vollkommen moment es
gibt kurze straße kam raus dass menschen
dann haben sie ist so lieb und hat
gesagt wenn ihr jetzt vollmilch okay so
jetzt bin ich hier an einem herd und
erhitze sahne und nicht auf kochen das
nur erhitzen wenn ihr merkt es wird
langsam warm ist wie gerade hoch steigen
dann den herr ausschalten und die
gehackte kuvertüre rhein geben
[Musik]
und jetzt muss nur noch die glasur
anziehen und dann können wir servieren
beziehungsweise wir haben noch ein paar
stunden bis zum fastenbrechen aber ihr
müsst jetzt nicht noch mal unnötig lange
kühl und alles in allem gelangen haben
jetzt gebraucht ohne zeit
ich wohne kühn zeit vielleicht 30 40
minuten wenn man ganz langsam ist ja man
verliert das zeitgefühl anfassen das
stimmt auf jeden fall werde ich es noch
dekorieren mit erdbeeren weil wir gerade
saison haben und ich finde dass ich
immer schick aus vielleicht nehme ich
auch noch pistazien dazu oder
kokosraspeln wir machen das einfach ganz
spontan nachher so und euch dann las ich
schon mal würde mich freuen wenn ihr
diesen liedern schulen würde mich freuen
wenn ihr den video im dörfchen nach oben
gibt genau und kommentar schreibt
vielleicht ist ja winter kam ist und
sowieso folgen
das ist ja ganz toll und vielleicht habt
ihr auch vorschläge was wir als nächstes
schönes machen können schreibt gerne
immer wieder rein und dann schreiben wir
auch miteinander in den kombi ist der
knüller aber dazu müssen wir eigentlich
sogar mein extra info video machen wir
da gibt es so viel zu erzählen so
brodelt uns genau also bis daneben
[Musik]